Good morning. Um, I
have to get started because that is of
course a lot to be said about sigma on
Friday.
Uh,
I actually, it's a shame I have
only 50 minutes for it and not, uh,
Dorsey, uh, lectures. Uh,
just before I get into a fried,
I just want to tell you that I did send
the questions already emailed it to use.
So if you check your email,
you have the questions for next year's
Day and I strongly encourage you to
attend the lectures and the
discussion sections. Uh,
those questions are not
necessarily very easy, so you,
you may want to get more
exposure beyond the readings,
uh,
to have a good handle on it.
And let me just a very,
very briefly come back to a nature,
uh,
before we go on to fried.
Why have you not phone fried
more than enough for today? Uh,
but I would like to ask,
still kind of rapid off and
to save on the bottom line is,
and uh,
the big question is to start with
what is genealogical mattered?
What is the new and in
the niches approach?
Um, and it should be clear from
the writings and from the lecture.
And I think from the discussion sections,
I,
that's what he's suggesting that
in the genealogical mattered, uh,
you viewed take, um, um, an
ideal and I'm more our principal,
uh,
what you think is the right idea.
And then he will show that one can
think about this idea different than
historically they did things differently.
And these major example is good.
Are you think an idea of what good is?
It's uncontestable easy to agree.
Well,
I will show you that in history had
an ocean of good and the opposite.
What is not good has been
constructed differently. Uh,
so the point of departure,
first of all the hell that is the Judaeo
Christian morality of Glaad and area.
I've your show, I've, you'll go back to
time. I go back to the antiquity and I've,
you'll show them the notion of God
was completely different, right?
Uh,
that is the general logical and
mattered a lot to do with consistently.
He really should be cleaning.
They're going back to the antiquity.
I'm suggesting that the good
in antiquity was the real good,
right?
It's just a comparative study which
relativizes the idea of God in your mind
today, uh, to make, uh,
you over there that God has been thought
about differently and different times.
And in particular,
of course,
his main focus is on the notion
of mortality in modern society.
And he said, well, that is something
unique about these modern society,
namely that morality somehow
is internalized into us
and we kind of accept our
own subjugation and oppression because
these values are so deeply invested in to
us. So that is in a way that
the general logic or metric, uh,
not to have, as I said in the
lecture, a critical vantage point,
try to get a vein that I will give you
the real universal definition of good and
ivy or criticize any question of mortality
from a universal concept of morality.
That's not what he does,
right? His major lame is, uh,
to show, uh, that, um, uh,
all morality's all conceptions
of moralities, all go,
all conceptions. Uh, what is, uh, um, uh,
uh, justice, uh, uh, what is fair,
what is humane and has been manufactured
right in the Virg sharp of ideals.
And this workshop I offer ideas is a dark
place that actually core shern torture
is being used to manufacture
these seemingly great ideas.
It's all about control, uh, over humans.
That's in a nutshell, right?
What niches trying to do?
So let me just make a step back.
Uh,
two marks and foreshadow
our staff for Vod to fried.
So these nature has reality
little disagreement of it.
Marx theory of Eliana nation.
He said they'll as long as mark,
she's saying that in the modern world
we are alienated because we are not
masters of our own fate.
I agree with him. Uh,
Raj Vr Elian in this world,
and we do not have power over our,
our life external conditions,
ECT like fet for nature,
a standard storm and determines our life.
He agrees with these diagnosis,
right of modernity.
His problem with marks is that
march comes to a solution, right?
Mark Says Bell,
I know what human emancipation
VOB I know about good society.
Vob and I know who will get us there,
right?
The proletariat. And he said,
this is, uh, you know, uh,
this is churlish that's,
that's no good. Right? Um,
uh, I've, I won't do that. I
won't fall into this trap. Right.
I feel not manufactured and other ideal
because my workshop then ideas would be
manufacturer would be also a
workshop which smells, right.
And which is full with coercion.
And I would subject others to uh,
um,
uh, torture, mental or physical torture.
In the good old days, it was
physical torture. Today it's worse.
It is mental torture, right?
That's in a nutshell, right?
But he's trying to, to achieve. Um,
and of course that is no fried.
There is no labor and there
is no Michelle for core. Uh,
there is really no modern
and postmodern social theory.
This out niches inside.
This is a radicalization
of critical theory, right?
Political theory,
we've talked about this right from
Hagle two marks was a critique of
consciousness.
That's what is in our mind is a
distortion of the reality, right?
And therefore they were trying to
subject human consciousness to critical
scrutiny. Nicha does it the
most radical way. He said,
I am capable to show,
right,
the shortcomings of our consciousness.
We such showing you what is
the right consciousness, right?
That's the project.
Now seeing one fried and has a
lot of similarities with this,
right? He's also a critical
theorist. And he says, the hell,
what is in our mind comes very deep down
from the repressed and Ivy will show
you, right? Um, how,
if this causes you neurotic responses,
I can actually cure you by the age of Sti.
Let you understand what has been
repressed in your life experience,
and then how you can do
something about yourself.
So that's in a nutshell,
Zigmund fries, uh, contribution.
So it basically follows
closely, uh, Q, um,
uh, niches, ideas, and in the piece,
particularly what I ask you to read today,
one of the pcs ride a
civilization and these,
these con then he's struggling very much
with the problem niches is struggling
yet, uh, he shows modern
civilization as repression,
right? At the same time, he does
not want to reject civilization,
right? And he's tormented, right? Uh,
how to evaluate civilization, right? Um,
and val, he probably is
not going as far as, uh,
uh, as nature. Nature does. Maybe
a seat. That's when it comes. Okay.
This is as ignorant fried.
Um,
and it's a good advertising.
Don't smoke.
Uh, you have his cigar. Uh, uh,
he has actually oral cancer.
He was suffering from it during the
last 20 years of his life and eventually
committed suicide.
And the cancer obviously has something
to do with his cigars who don't smoke.
Um, well, uh, Freud was one
of the giants, uh, um, uh,
for 19 and early 20th century thought.
Um,
many people who would name the,
the intellectual giants of these time
a 19th century would name three names,
Charles Darwin,
Karl Marx and Sigmund Fried,
right?
These are the three thinkers
which made a rethink ourselves,
who we are and where we come from.
And uh,
what is the nature of the society
we live in the most radical ways.
Okay. Uh, let me talk very
briefly about, uh, uh,
fried slide.
Uh,
Eve was born in 1856 in what
is now the Czech Republic,
more rvr southern part
of the Czech Republic.
In a small city called she boy. Um, uh,
his father was a Jewish world merchant.
Um,
he was, uh, uh, or that he
married to his third wife,
uh, was about 20 years. His Junior.
He was a pretty dominating
figure. Uh, the mother was, uh,
on the other hand, a very
sensitive human being. Um,
uh, in some ways, uh, uh,
Fried's troubled relationship be
the aging authoritarian father.
And we had the soft spoken,
kind,
forced coming and warm mother does
explain a locked about his thinking about,
uh, um, uh, human life. Uh,
very soon after he was born,
he, they moved away for,
she bore a first be free divert in
Leipzig and then they moved to Vienna.
And this is where, uh, uh, uh,
Zignal fried received his education.
Um,
in 73,
he enrolled at the University of Vienna.
He was studying law for the VI.
He got very bored with it.
So he shifted into medical school and
received his medical degree in 81 and
[inaudible] two in the major
university hospital in Vienna,
which is scarred genital hospital. Um, um,
uh, in 85, uh, very briefly,
he went to study, uh, to Paris. Uh,
and this was very cool show
for his change, uh, because,
uh,
he became interested here in neurology
and especially became interested and in a
therapy about a French,
a psychiatrist was used and that foss
hypnosis to cheat hysteria and sort of,
he came back to Vienna and he decided
that he will now become a neurologist,
interested particularly in hysteria,
and we'll use hypnosis as a clarity.
Um, he also married in
86 as a life long. And,
uh, you know, uh, very, uh, uh,
peaceful marriage. Uh,
um, Martha Bernard's,
who was a granddaughter of
the Chief Rabbi of Hamburg,
so it's coming from a
deeply Jewish family,
but he himself had very
little faith in his life.
He began to practice
psychotherapy and he saw,
set up an office in a barrack Schrafft's,
a mind seeing a 19 barrack
stress saying central Vienna.
Here it is, the house today. Well, uh,
Zigman Fried,
uh,
start that to practice and
practice that until 1938.
And this is where psychoanalysis was born.
So,
uh, an important house. Um, so, um,
after 86,
right,
begin to collaborate with another app,
psychologist Joseph Broyer and Broyer,
I was not using the hype naughty care,
hypnotic,
a hypnotic metrics. Uh, what he did, uh,
he did something,
what he called the talking cure.
This is something what you occasionally
do or your friends do witchu right?
If something is on your chest,
then you call your friend and you say,
I need somebody to talk to right
now has some, some real big,
big trouble in you.
You want somebody to listen right now,
this is exactly what Brian did.
He did ask his patients,
uh, to talk to him, right?
And turned out that these,
a talking cure was very effective.
Uh,
as you probably all experience,
right when something is on your chest
and you have a good friend who is willing
to listen and does not rush
to give you advice and I,
this is whom you want, right?
Just to listen and nod,
to be sympathetic and tried to understand
you and let you talk and ask the good
questions, but not to give her advice,
right? There's four broiler discovered,
well in 1895,
they coauthored a book
studies in hysteria. Um,
and now they actually in the book
suggests that there must be a new therapy.
Don't put people asleep,
but make them Clark and led them
freely associate and through this free
association you throw verse in and then
they beginning to freely associated to
this world you actually can uncover.
They beginning to use
the term unconscious.
That is an unconscious
level in every individual.
And with this free association
you can dip into the unconscious.
Um, and in fact it was
fried who in doing this,
practicing this with
patients, uh, uh, also,
uh,
began to understand that a lot
of stuff in the subconscious is,
has something to do with
sexuality. And it is, you know,
unsatisfied on,
achieved sexual desires,
which are kind of repressed
into the subconscious.
And then through this free associations,
it was digging into the unconscious.
He began to discover,
um, a lot of sexual stuff. Um,
and then one year later it is
right. A very important, uh, uh,
they in the history of modern
social thought in 1896,
he finally has a name for what he
does and he calls it psycho analysis.
Um, uh, and, uh, here it is a,
if you have not seen this picture yet,
you should.
This was the famous couch.
That's where the patient had to lay down.
And Freud of us sitting
in an armchair and, uh,
listening to what they got
to say. Um, and, uh, uh,
uh,
asking just a couple of probing questions,
but the essence of
psychoanalysis is that I,
that you do not solve the
problem for the patient.
The patient has to find its own
solution that psychoanalysis a veal,
know what the problem is.
Eventually be a lead you that bring it
from the subconscious into the conscious
and then it is because
it becomes conscious.
You suddenly realize you
can't deal with it. Um,
now what about the later, very just
very briefly, it's a voluminous, uh,
uh, uh, in, uh, 1899,
he published a book which is
called interpretation of dreams.
And a,
it's to a large extent is
analysis of his own dreams,
but also the dreams of
some of his patients. Uh,
his father just passed away and we,
the dad of the father,
he had a great deal of guilt,
why he had these heat feeling
of his father. It was a hate,
love relationship, but, um, uh,
strongly motivated by hate. Um, and, uh,
uh,
he began to analyze himself and trying
to figure out what his problem with his
father was and what his relationship
with the moderate and father was.
And interpretation of dreams is a
very important step in this direction.
And the fundamental idea in these
past be breaking book that in fact,
dreams are not actually a dental.
Uh,
dreams are the time of this little window
of opportunity when some of the stuff
from the unconscious tries to come
up into the conscious. So therefore,
what he did,
he made people to remember their dreams
and then he tried to help them from the
material, which was surfacing
from dreams to understand, uh,
the subconscious.
Uh,
in 1905,
there is another major breakthrough is
publishing and the pathology of everyday
life, um, in which you,
you all know this term,
the Friday and slippage and
somebody just by accident,
some of got something wrong,
slips his strong and says something
differently than it should. The,
a fry does a show that very often
it's actually also the subconscious,
a good thing his head up and he is an
indication what is in your subconscious.
But is it a blessing?
Knew it was just not an error what
you did right beyond these errors,
he can see, uh, the
subconscious coming up.
And then of course the same year and
other major breakthrough probably next to
the discovery of [inaudible] is
the most important breakthrough,
the three essays on the
theory of sexuality.
And now he is moving towards what
some will say call a pan sexual,
just understanding of the mind,
uh,
well is probably pushing it too far.
Uh,
most what do not believe in fried,
so that are still many,
many people who do believe in
Freud, right? That are people who,
and I have this psycho
analysis and you know, just 10,
20 years ago, I mean, everybody
has his, his analysts, right.
Interesting. Now think somehow this
is a little going out of fashion,
but I think that are still people.
You must know people, right,
to have the analysts strat and they go
every other week to the analyst lay down
on the couch and you know, they speak
their mind and then they kind of relieved,
well, I would say, you know,
if have problems of depression,
why don't you try actually I think
does certainly does do less damage than
taking, uh, uh, this bloody pills.
What can not, not, not, not
that I, when I just cannot,
of course he would trouble because
these cycles of course all know,
because uh, for, for
our theory of sexuality,
uh, that all these problems
in us is that press,
sexual desires and everything has to
do something with our early childhood
experiences for boys with the
love of your mother and um,
and jealousy of your
father. And um, uh, uh, uh,
uh, right. Uh, uh, and it
goes the other way around.
Well also,
if you go to an analyst in no time,
he will start figuring golf value.
You really hate your father
or you hate your mother. Uh,
and well,
I'm not so sure that's the best thing,
but it can happen to you. But anyway,
that's what what he was doing.
And he in fact, you know,
he uh, um, discovers a,
I think an intriguing idea and
I think psychologists do these,
they are struggling with it.
How much trues that destroyed
the SOCOM. Saul, God,
early purse complex.
And you know what early posts complex ne
is the early post by accident marriage,
his own wife or mother of
any turns out that mother,
and that's of course a big tragedy, right?
You are not supposed to. This is incest,
uh,
which is the,
you're surely all civilizations
prohibited, incest,
um,
bow and this is early posts
complex that we are all those uh,
um, in lover. Uh, we, uh, uh, uh,
our balance of the opposite
sex and jealous of, uh,
of, of the other, uh, other parent,
right and do early push complex also
means that we have a desire to kill our
father in order to have the love.
In fact,
sexual love it off our imagine if you
had boys and Mash rivers are for girls.
Now I think everybody would agree this
probably pushed the idea a bit too far,
but that is clearly an interesting,
very important insight in the argument.
Then in the liter,
very, he is moving more to
have arts met up psychology.
Now he tries to explain the functioning
of society rather than just individual
UB psyche.
Uh,
the first major step in this direction
is 1913 when he published the book totem
and Taboo.
And this is about the origins
are fairly primitive society.
The transformation from a
kinship networks stretch tribal,
larger tribal society.
And he explains in this book
the origins of uh, uh, you know,
first complex society as the brothers
come together and they killed their father
and the father exercise that
in the kinship relationship,
absolute power. And in fact, uh,
he also believed that in these
early kinship based societies,
there was even no incest taboo.
So the fact that actually could
have sex, uh, we had, uh, um,
if his daughter says, well, now
the brothers come together, uh,
they kill the father and they
create the first civilization.
They beginning to wrap dress
desires, um, and uh, share,
uh, uh, uh, power among themselves. Uh,
that's a total Manta will.
Then he writes to important to you that
a conceptual basis beyond the pleasure
principle 1920,
and they go and eat.
And I asked you to read some of it,
1923 which are kind of,
uh,
important conceptual elements.
And I think this all culminated in his
a civilization and its discontents 19
Kirti,
which arguably if you are not
interested in individual psychology,
but the theory of society,
this is his most important book was
very big success and has not been out of
print endeavors since dirt the eighth.
He has to leave Vienna. He had, um,
a similar here at love
relationship to the city of Vienna,
stove out his father as many people did a,
but by 38,
the Nazis took it over a
guest star who actually, um,
interviewed, uh, uh,
his daughter a lot better love
to daughter Ana and sort of he,
he show the writing on the raw.
It's time to leave if you are Jewish,
you don't want to live in the term dry.
And he moves to London.
And just a year later he actually
called my commits suicide.
It's as an assisted suicide,
um, uh, his doctor, how Tim,
uh, to get rid of the pain he was
struggling with for a very long time.
Bell, a bit about UB psychoanalytic
movement. Fried's ideas. We are of course,
outrageous, outrageous
ideas. A very controversial,
never the last very early on or daddy
or 19 or two that are really a group of
very young and the evil people,
which included people like
Shandra Ferenczi and Carl
younger and they hadn't the
Strawns who wrote their Vondra fool,
a biography of the definite
biography of fried, if you want.
Of course, a very profiled the end,
uh, perspective, uh, to read it.
It's a great book. Um, eh indeed.
And they start to gather
in Beck set nine seen, um,
in Vietnam every events day this was
called events deep psychological circle.
Then in 1908, this becomes a, uh,
the VN up psychological society.
A bit of a misnomer because in no time
he's beginning to spread around the world
and that are psychoanalytic societies
all over delivered on deal this very day.
And if you want to become an analyst,
it's not enough to have a medical degree.
You have to go through years of
very rigorous training, um, uh,
um, uh, to these siteground artists
or scientists, we are monitored.
Uh, fried was also a very
difficult person to get along.
He basically had fallouts
with everybody first,
probably the most important of his
earliest associate Adler already in 1911.
They break up then with younger,
uh, you know, Adler Young,
good next to Adler are the dominant
figures of psychology in the first two or
three decades of the 20th century.
Then even later on,
he breaks with fancy,
who was a pretty loyal guy,
was not easy to get a fallout with him,
but you know,
Froud managed this, you know, he
couldn't make enemies everywhere.
Okay. Um, uh, then the really the
person who was running the show, uh,
uh, became, uh, um, uh,
his daughter or not fried,
uh,
who live the long life, uh, and, uh, uh,
hold up the torch and carried
the causal psychoanalysis.
So let me have a look at the work on,
uh, the Eggo. Not Arrogant. I'm sorry.
That's the EGL and [inaudible], right? Uh,
this is a Friday and slippage. It's, uh,
I have two glass.
They swap now that I,
he said that here he is beginning to move.
The initial idea is that is subconscious
or unconscious and conscious element,
what constitutes the human sexuality.
And now he wants to have a clearer
conceptual at banner to tools to deal with
this.
And he has bell,
our perception system has three
components. One is the ego,
uh, the other one is either,
and the third one is super ego.
And we will deal with all of this, right?
And therefore, what is interesting,
what is an introduction between ego
ID and Super Ego and this content and
civilization. They are
sweet, disagree deal.
These also talking about the
two classes of instincts.
What guy's life and that's
also important for um, uh,
see realization. And this one
valley, he said, you know,
initially we made a distinction between
the conscious and the unconscious.
Um,
and uh,
the idea of unconscious game from
the theory of repression that we have
unconscious because some of the
experiences we do not recall,
for instance,
our sexual desire to or
murder which was prohibited.
It's pushed into our subconscious and
other unpleasant experiences in our life.
We want to forget and be
put into subconscious.
That's [inaudible] you're repress.
We are oppressed and
on desired experience,
uh, here, unconscious, right coins sided,
uh, with what is latent and
what wants to become conscious,
wants to enter the conscious. These only
supressed than it is psycho analysis,
which helps you to bring
this into the consciousness.
But he said, well, it's
all that is repressed,
is unconscious. That's, that's
quite shoe. You know, um,
if you had bad memories,
you,
you tend to forget it and
put it into the unconscious.
But the big discovery was what not.
All that is unconscious is necessity.
Rewrap breasts that are
stuff in the unconscious,
which was there before
it was in consciousness.
Uh, uh, you said the lecture,
which is unconscious only descriptively,
not dynamically,
dynamically, man, it was depressed,
but that is an element of subconscious,
which is their only descriptively,
right?
This is what he called pre consciousness.
Before it,
it was never in the conscious,
right?
This just deep down in you.
Um, and uh, well, uh, he shed
viewed esteemed the term,
I'm conscious to the
dynamically unconsciousness,
breasts and now the two,
these repressed unconscious and the
preconscious together via constitute,
I suppose it now he
can now currently play,
but who have different
concepts now, fried, set,
conscious,
pre conscious and unconscious.
And the question is what
is the relationship between
those? So what is Eagle?
He said that each
individual and that is a,
a coherent organization
of the mentor process.
And this is what we call ego, right? Um,
uh,
well it is to this eagle that
consciousness is attached.
What is consciousness is as
is what is Eden. He said,
it is also a mental agency,
right? Which supervises,
um, uh, and constitutes the
process of thinking, ah,
he sat,
which goes to sleep,
but at the same time he's exercises
control even over your dreams.
That's your equal.
Um,
and the eagle is the agents of repression,
the ego VL repressed stuff,
which is in the way of the Eagle to act
that will push it into the unconscious.
Uh,
well he said,
therefore our therapy was to try to
bring into the ego what was unconscious,
right, and what else repressed.
Um, but that is something else,
uh,
which is not a repressed,
which also has a very important drive.
And this is it,
right?
Is What is deeply down in
your, your, those desires,
the drives which come out
of you and they are not,
some of it is not,
has never been repressed.
Does just by nature in you, for
instance, Shat sexual drives,
right? So I propose,
uh, the car, the entity,
which starts out from the
system of preconscious and
begins by the conscious and
the room and called the other part
of the mining to which these antique,
the extents and which behaves
through it as if it were unconscious.
The it,
it's unconscious but not repressed or
combination of repressed and preconscious.
Well,
uh,
he said the ego is very sharply
separately. The, the, uh,
from the IED, uh, it's
really the air, the,
uh, is uh, uh, below the ego
and that's the value, the,
this probably the best of graphs,
but he said the eagles or relationship
to the Ed is like a man on a horse back
right after the ride that is obliged to
guide the horse that the horse wants to
go. Right. This is the ID, right?
So the Eagle Vob in on the Horse,
the horse is the Ed. But occasionally
if you don't want to follow the horse,
you'd have the whole school by
the horse long to go. All right.
You try to control the horse, but that
is so much you can do about the horse.
It's a very important
idea and mature for us.
And then there comes the
Super Ego, right? He said,
the ego is not merely a part of the Ed.
All right?
There also exists that agreed in the ego,
which may be called the
ego ideal or the Super Ego,
right?
And a part of this ego is for the,
uh, you know, Hermie connected
to the consciousness.
Um, uh, um, and Vail, uh,
the Super Ego, right as
the, uh, he said, uh,
is part of a residue of earlier
object choices of the Ed.
Um,
uh,
but it represents an energetic reaction
formation against those choices.
It, it is what tells you what
you should be, not what you are.
The Ego tells you who you are,
right?
The Ego test a version
of reality and tests,
but you cannot achieve under the
conditions of reality, right?
The Super Ego is that part
of your consciousness, uh,
which actually will tell you
that what you should be right?
Adam Smith's,
you remember Adam Smith's the theory of
moral sentiment that is somebody inside
you with watching you and
makes a judgment on you.
Whether this is right or wrong.
The idea of super ego is very similar,
right to these Adam Smithian idea.
Uh, well sacco analysis you said was, uh,
criticize us for ignoring the higher
values in human life and ongoingly only
about sex and so on and so forth,
is that this is all wrong.
We are very aware of the existence of
the SIP Super Ego and that is a complex
introduction between ego ID and Super Ego.
Uh, well, ego is essentially
replicate safe. Uh, uh,
it's, it's, it's essentially
represents the external reality.
The external Verdis such a,
the Super Ego on the other hand represents
the internal of you on a view of what
you would want to be,
though you cannot be partially
because your drive sab dirty, right?
And you need to go does not
let you to achieve that. Right?
Uh,
so I actually bought,
belonged to the last part of the
mental life, right? The suppress stuff.
Uh, um, uh,
it's turned into what is the
highest in the human mind, right?
The Super Ego. Now that are
also two classes of instincts.
One instinct, what he discovered
early in the work is, uh, um,
uh, uh, what he, uh,
uh, calls libido, right?
The sexual desire and the desire to
live and survive and self preservation.
But there is another instinct in us.
It discovers she's somewhat later in
life and this is the desk in state that
Donatos so that are arrows.
And Donato Swan is what makes us live.
The other is destructive once to bring
us to this and the human life and the
human history can be understood as a
struggle between the arrows and Donatos.
Such a sad deism is a good
example of a tomato's.
Um, he said, uh, okay, uh,
let me move to civilization and discontent
and that are the major highlights
about ego development, uh,
religion and purposes of life.
Uh, a civilization as
restriction, uh, of, um,
sexual life. Um, uh, uh,
I got about ego development that is not
that much I have to add or interpret
here. Uh, well, uh, he said, uh,
um, uh, the ego eventually
have all seen us.
It's not just given in us,
right?
It sharply differentiated.
I can see this person
who has a strong ego.
You present your ego very
strongly and your ear,
the is being hidden from,
um, you know, if I've,
if I can, um, uh, uh,
put it fit Erving Goffman ride
the EOD is in the backstage.
You don't show it right that it,
but once you want to present is,
is your eagle. Um, uh, uh,
but this,
uh,
dwarves gradually right in the
process of human development.
You can see as eagle gradually
develops in a child, um,
and takes the form as it is and one
important process in this as you move away
from the pleasure principle to
the reality principle, right?
Is that a purpose of human life? He
asks, well, only religion can answer.
Talk to you about the purpose of life.
Uh,
I was a psychologist or a social
analyst or social scientists.
I cannot tell you about the purpose of
life is what is the purpose of life.
Now he comes very close to
the utilitarian idea, right?
The almost here. Um, uh,
John Stuart Mill, uh,
speaking to him, happiness. We
are all striving to be happy. Now.
I bought on the,
unfortunately,
the problem is that it's much easier
to be unhappy than to be happy.
Uh, uh, uh,
and because we are confronted
with the problems, uh, uh,
that, uh, uh, in fact, uh, uh,
on the happiness is much likely to be our
faith then achieve what we want to be.
Happiness. Uh, these, uh,
pleasure principle is transformed
into a reality principle.
We save out. That is the reality
of what we have to accept.
Um, uh, and you have to escape this.
We need to have this reality principle
to bring our unhappiness under control,
uh,
to be able to survive a sufferings.
We have to have a sense of reality.
And this is the painting of the ego.
This now become very close
to nature as close as a,
uh, um, uh, fried ever VOB right?
And the sub Lee nation of instinct,
that's all about civilization
is all about right?
The feeling of happiness is derived from
the satisfaction of vide intellectual
impulses untamed by the Eagle,
the blonde beast,
right?
That's where a pleasure comes from,
but it has to be tamed. All
right, here comes right.
The very measured on each and idea,
and this is happening through the process,
you know, um, if, uh,
on a long two s keep it,
then you,
you'll do it.
You'll become maniac or intoxicated.
You know,
if you cannot, uh, uh,
a feast dirty Allity,
then you drink, right? Uh, all
right. Uh, it was too much.
So I go to the pub and I ordered a double
scotch, right? And then I relax, right?
Uh, intoxication is the
way how to avoid reality.
I get drunk. Um, many people get drunk,
a very bad idea because actually it feel,
make it worse.
You're on unhappiness.
As soon as the first,
a few minutes of happiness is fast,
we be just verse.
Now. Uh, and uh, uh,
another way to do it is
sublimation, right? Of the instinct.
You suppress an end all in some days.
These instincts,
that's that actually, uh, the, uh, you'll,
you'll move into sphere of fantasies.
You fantasize rather than live out,
uh, you were depressed desires. And
this is the mechanism of fantasy,
which creates art and science.
And the most noble human activities are
actually sublimated unsatisfied desires,
right? Which came from the
ego. The came from the ear,
the ego confronted with reality and then
suppressed it and then was sublimated
into this higher, um, uh, um,
elements where,
uh,
he has a very nice
quotation from Gerta on, uh,
an unpublished poem and not,
uh,
surprisingly unpublished,
uh, this, uh, as, uh, um,
the people, uh, who have, uh, uh,
science and art also to have religion.
Um,
those who do not have either science
or art have to have religion.
Now it's a very interesting
guy. They said, in fact,
I don't think it is totally
obvious how you have to interpret
the special, the first part,
I think it's a v one can interpret the
first sentence of [inaudible] business,
how to [inaudible]. Uh,
it, it basically means,
well, you know, science and
art is a sort of analogy.
And if you are actually a
scientist or an artist, you have,
you diligent and you even
don't have to be religious.
But if you have no
signs or, or, or no art,
in order to make sense of the life,
you need religion. Right? And that's,
I think it's, uh, not, not,
not surprising that he never
published the point. Now, um,
fry pushes far.
He is also antireligious and he said,
well,
indeed religion is just mass delusion
because it does create the impression,
right,
that you can actually more the
reality that there is purpose of life,
probably not in these areas,
but beyond that and you will
be able to achieve that.
That's why he calls it mass delusion.
You don't confront reality, right?
You do not develop your
reality principle sufficiently.
Uh,
uh,
and of course he also caused this infant
dial infant died because you create the
figure of the God, the
Father God. And he said,
this is exactly the young
in the fence reaction,
how to respond to danger and the reality
to hope that you will get protections
from your father.
And he said,
this is exactly what religions are
calling upon my life, you know,
event venue address God as s my father.
Uh,
okay. That are different sources
of unhappy and NASA. Um, uh,
uh,
first of all,
the nature is source of our unhappiness
is superior and one part of nature is
particularly source of unhappiness,
our own body. And you know,
if you are getting sick
and old like Freud dead,
it will appreciate more and more how
much unhappiness comes from your body,
what you don't necessarily feel right now,
but wait 50 more years
and you via, uh, okay. Uh,
and that is the biggest unhappiness
actually comes from human relations.
So again, something which
resembles a, uh, very much, uh, uh,
the young Marx alienation,
um, as a Rdna from,
from your fellow human being and
of course a very much a to meet Ya,
right? Uh, that the problem
is in, in human relations. Um,
now, uh, uh,
now the question is how onerous he can
solve this problem of human relations.
Uh, and because we have this big
problem, right in human relations,
people start blaming civilization,
like, you know, niche idea.
Um, and well, um, Eh, Eh,
I bet he said it is in fact conceivable
that man in earlier age is rather than
in modernity actually were
happier than they are today. Uh,
noble savages, right? Their happiness
in the state of nature. Rousseau,
he said, well, that's not
on reasonable argument,
but how does civilization developed?
Uh,
well he said suggest he's proceeding two
of are more and more control over the
external word,
but also true of us.
Extension of the number of
people included in the community.
Therefore more and more control
over other people, right?
This is sort of civilization
is a technology,
how to be able to control more people,
control nature and more people.
Yes, we already talked
about the totem and taboo.
You will see this on the Internet.
Um,
anyway,
or culture.
All civilizations are coming from the
oppression and this is a very important
insight. Very similar
to niches, a critique,
right of morality and Andy in particular,
civilization,
restaurants, uh, sexual life. Well,
the important IEM of civilization to
bring many people together into a society.
And, uh, uh, the, uh,
limit of uninhabited
sexual love, right? Uh,
it restricts sexual life.
He said his high mark was reached investor
in European civilization. It's, again,
almost, you read almost
Nicha right here. Um, uh,
a choice of an object is restricted to
the opposite sex and the morst extra
genital satisfaction are
forbidden asper version.
Uh, but, uh,
even heterosexual Janet Lav is rest
shifted all his sexual relationship on the
basis of solitary in those,
in the salute will bond between Vong
man and van of one woman is what is
accepted in Western civilization,
not in order stabilization.
And that is the more stress,
oppressive system of sexuality. Right?
Uh, uh, uh, uh,
right. And there is actually more to it
rather than the repression of sexuality.
You know, it has to, uh,
whereas all other kind of,
uh, drives, which is coming from the Ed,
it teaches you are right, uh, to, uh, uh,
love your neighbor and even
your enemy, which is, uh, uh,
in his view ride, uh, impossible, uh,
Barta of l uh, um, uh,
we have to control some house aggressivity
who will [inaudible] is the wolf of
man. I, this is kind of hops, Ian,
theory of human nature are
deeply down the are actually,
that is also a critique of mark smart
things. That is an easy solution.
You eliminate private ownership and homo
whom in Amarillo most will be solved.
He said this is naive.
Uh, this does not happen.
That I don't have time
to work on this. Um, uh,
though it's a very interesting idea.
Narcissism.
And why you dislike particular
widget schools to you? Uh,
well, um, uh, uh,
I think I probably just have to leave
this here and just finish with the north,
uh, suggesting that uh, he
is actually very troubled.
He shows they're passive
nature of civilization,
but he does not want to buy
into the Nazi NTC realization.
Right. And he said, well, um,
I am not suggesting the super ego is
not necessarily super ego is necessary,
but I'm concerned about the super
ego to be tire at Ryan Nicole, right.
And less chart, you'll
find a middle way, right.
In which that's not be
naive. The Eod, uh, gifts,
uh, bad impulses, and they have
to be controlled by the Super Ego.
The Super Ego can go cool.
Far and too much.
So kind of ties to walk a narrow
way between marks and Nicha.
Alright.
Alrighty.